For the grace of God offers salvation
to all people teaching us
to live Godly life.
Jesus gave himself for us to redeem us and to
purify for himself a people that
are his very own.
For we ourselves were once foolish.
disobedient
let us stray.
slaves to various passions and pleasures
passing our days in Malice and envy
hated by others and hating one another
but
when the goodness and loving kindness of God our savior appeared
he saved us.
Not because of Works done by us in righteousness. But
according to his own Mercy.
By the washing of regeneration and renewal of
the Holy Spirit.
Whom he poured out on us richly through Jesus Christ
Our Savior.
So that being justified by his grace we
might become heirs according to the hope of
eternal life.
It's not so rich.
so deep
so incredibly beautiful.
Taking us from death to life from Darkness
to light all by the grace and mercy
of God our savior.
Now, I know it sounds like a broken record every week. It's
the same message that you get here at Henderson Hills and
it's not because we can't come up with something more creative. It's because
we Delight in it so much.
And it's so wonderful because it's all of God.
It's not by works.
It's not by any goodness in ourselves. It was
all according to his Mercy.
and listen that truth
if anything
should stun us.
Right shouldn't it it lead us to humility.
surrender to Brokenness
There's a lot of talk about Revival and Awakening going on in our land right
now a lot of conversations about that but hear me the
only way that that truly comes is
through individuals humbly repenting and
being broken before the Lord.
It's through you and me saying God we
want nothing else but you through US
breaking our hearts before him and letting
him break our hearts and surrendering to him. That's the only way
this happens.
In fact, would you pray?
daily
that God would do that in US.
That this is not just business as usual that we don't just go through
the motions of being Christians in America.
That's something truly changes.
In fact, let's pray for that right now. I don't know why we would wait.
Let's pray right now God. Thank you for this this moment
that you have ordained. This is not an accident
that every one of us is here or watching. It's it's that you
have
put us here and you've put this text and
and your glory in front of us God.
so Lord, I pray as
as it's so easy for us to come into
this room or or go through the motions and
just think it's another thing.
Don't let us.
Stagnate God don't let us be content
with the same thing.
But drive us back to your word back to
the depths of the Gospel the good news.
Of your grace and mercy and our place.
Break us.
Break our hearts God open our hands.
Thank you that that's what these students have been hearing all weekend of
of how it's not about being a superhero of
Faith. It's just doing the normal God
designed things to do daily in
faith.
And you transform the world through that.
God awaken their hearts may may this start
as it has throughout history in our
young people.
And flood through our church God that
they awaken to the fact that Jesus you're worth it.
To give everything away.
To count Our Lives as nothing and say Jesus you are
better.
What do you want me to do?
every moment every day every year
What do you want?
Me that be true of all of us.
Start with this Lord.
You've brought us to this moment. And so
God show us what you want for each of us.
Start with me.
Start with us that our church is different
because of you.
Help us God.
If you're not already there.
Titus 3 that's where we're going to be today.
Titus 3 1 through 8
I've read most of it. We've read it a couple times actually because it's so
good. But this is the whole passage Titus 3 1 through
8.
Paul writing to Titus on Crete says remind them to
be submissive to rulers and authorities to obedient
to be ready for every good work to speak
evil of no one to avoid quarreling to
be gentle and to show perfect courtesy toward all
people.
Four we ourselves were once foolish disobedient
LED astray slaves to various passions and Pleasures
passing our days in Malice and envy hated by
others hating one another but when the goodness
and loving kindness of God our savior appeared he saved us
not because of Works done by us and righteousness. But
according to his own Mercy by the washing regeneration
renewal the Holy Spirit.
Whom he poured out on us richly through Jesus Christ Our Savior.
So that being justified by his grace we might become heirs
according to the hope of eternal life.
The sayings trustworthy and I want you to insist on these
things so that those who have believed in God
may be careful to devote themselves to
Good Works.
These things are excellent and profitable for
people.
Now you notice a couple times this passage talks about Good Works.
But you saw it clearly in verse 5 that nothing in
those good works actually bring Salvation.
You've got to keep that in mind the rest of today. I know
James 2 says faith without works is dead. It's useless
but that doesn't contradict what Ephesians chapter 2
verses 8 9 say about why Works can't
save you it says by Grace you've been saved through faith.
This is not your own doing. It's the gift of God not
a result of works so that no one can boast.
See, that's the point. If you could save yourself then you
could boast about it. You'd be the one
getting Glory but God says no, I want the glory. I am the one
worthy of glory. And so I'm Gonna Save you not by
anything you did.
And so if Works don't save us then what are they for?
What James meant is that they are the confirmation of
your faith in Jesus. They go together faith and
works go together. They're what God uniquely designed
each one of us to do in
order to bless those around us.
That's what Ephesians 2:10 continues. He says for
we are God's workmanship created in
Christ Jesus for good works.
Which God prepared beforehand that we should walk in them?
And so you see this is part of the deal somehow good works
works into this thing, right?
Well, here's how you could remember. This is the the main thing
if you walk away remembering nothing else kind of remember this as you
walk away clearly we saw here that God does not
need your good works.
But your neighbor does.
God doesn't need it like you you can't offer anything to God.
You can't earn anything from God so he doesn't need them.
But as you surrender to him.
in humility
as you live a sacrificial life and response to
his grace.
Those people around you are recipients of
God's blessing through you.
That's why good works are a part of this equation.
God doesn't need them, but your neighbor does.
So here in this passage, just like last week we come back
to the same thing over and over again every week. But but the
Apostle Paul last week spent a good chunk of the verses just
exalting in the grace of God celebrating the
gospel, right?
That he was reminding the church Jesus life death and
Resurrection in their place is why this thing works? It's the
whole point of all of it. I don't think here in chapter 3,
he forgot that he wrote it a couple sentences early. He's just
saying it again because it's that important.
He just says it again. He's like the gospel. And
then this is what you do the gospel. And this is what you do. It's that
important because we cannot forget this that the gospel is
the source of all of this.
in everything the rest of today this whole thing falls apart without
the gospel being the source the foundation The
Rock on which we stand and we know it's the
source of all of this because of the first word of verse 3.
It's the word for f o r.
Remember, that's a linking word.
That means whatever. He just said
is dependent on what he's about to say.
So in verses 1 and 2 he laid out a series of indicatives. He said
do this do this do this.
And then verse 3 begins with that word for because
in order that so you would say do all
these things why because or do
all these things. How because
and what does he say next?
the gospel
versus three through seven is a
truth. That should change the entire orientation
of Our Lives.
Do all these things not just to do them because of
the gospel. And so we do this
every week. I know it sounds like a broken record, but we treasure it. It's our
source. So we are going to just marvel again at the
gospel because the scripture does
But here's how we're going to do it this interesting. The way Paul goes
about this and Titus 3. Is he he kind of
sets up this picture of three men now
women you're included in this men man meaning like
person human.
You might think of it that way and so first you'll see what I mean. When
I get there first in verse 3 Paul described
what he refers to as the old
man.
The old person the old man is what we
might say here and so look again at verse
3. This is what I mean the old person of Who
We Are
For we ourselves were once foolish disobedient. Let
us stray slaves to various passions and
Pleasures passing our days and Malice or anger and
envy hated by others and hating one
another.
Cuts that's a pretty pretty Stark picture, right?
This is a lost person is what he says.
But really hear me, this is all of us.
Before we meet Christ notice. He says we ourselves he's
including himself. He's including the Crete and Believers because
remember where they were saved from in chapter 1 verse 12,
they were lazy. They were evil beasts lazy
gluttons, right? They were they were these people that were all known
for their sin.
and then he says but we
ourselves
all of us are included in that now you might have read that.
That verse 3 you might have read that and thought wow that that sure
is pretty extreme.
It's pretty hard. Like that's not I don't see that a lot
anywhere.
Now I'll give it to you that there are varying degrees of how
this plays out in the world today. Right not all of us are addicted to
meth not everybody's Hitler right? Like we know that not
everybody gets fired for outbursts at work, right? There are levels
of how this plays out in our lives.
But here's how I see it most often today in our
world.
Our context most people are like me when I was
growing up.
learning how to manage
all of that
old man stuff
and manipulate it in such a way to look religious so
that you get what you want in the end.
And it's all about self.
So yeah, you don't look like all that the wickedness out there, but you
look the same in the end.
disobedient
the parents right? Because no matter how this plays out. It's still in
there. Right? We're all disobedient to parents. We cheat on tests. We
lie to people right that's in here. We foolishly follow
selfish desires that's in here. We
put other people down to lift ourselves up that's in
here.
This is all of us. This is the old man.
This is every lost person in the world. This is the
lifestyle that First Corinthians 6 says will not inherit
the kingdom of God.
And it's not just the bad stuff out there. It's every little
Nuance we could find in
that that this is what keeps us from the kingdom of
God, maybe.
Maybe you see yourself there today.
maybe look at that verse and you're thinking that's
who I am.
And you've tried everything you can't get out of
it.
You've tried to be religious you've tried to go to Camp. You've tried to do all the
things and and nothing has worked and you cannot get out. Well
thankfully hear me that does not have to be the end of
your story.
Thankfully for all that's not the end of the story here
right verse 4 has a great word to start it off. We
saw the first word of verse 3.
This one's three letters as well the first word of verse
4 b u t.
And that word means that something difference coming.
Right something different is next what I just said, actually there's
something different and just like Titus 2:11 said
something different showed up not just something
different was next something different showed up. Look at
Titus 3:4.
but when the goodness and loving kindness
of God our savior appeared
now remember that wasn't just a theory.
That was actually a person.
When Grace appeared that was talking about Jesus same kind
of thing here verse 5 starts with the fact that he saved
us. So goodness loving kindness showed up, but
it was a person. That's Jesus.
He showed up.
Means he is Grace. He is goodness. He is
loving kindness all those things that showed up he is
that
and so yes Paul describes in verse 3
the old man. This is what it looks like to be lost. But here
in verse 4 the god Man shows up.
The old man was this way the god Man shows up
to do something different. That's Jesus. Right? That's fully God
fully man in one Jesus Christ.
Who shows up and changes everything?
Says he brought Grace as a gift.
Showing a Salvation is not by our own efforts.
It's a gift you just receive but he also
it says here he brought Mercy.
Now grace and mercy think of a coin these are the opposite
sides of the same coin grace and mercy.
And here's how you can think about it Grace.
Is where you get what you don't deserve.
Right God's grace. He just gives it to
us. We don't deserve anything, but he says here salvation. That's
Grace.
The flip side is Mercy.
Which is not getting what you do
deserve.
We've all experienced that at some point in our lives whether it's from a parent
or from a teacher or something where where you know, I blew
it.
And I should get this discipline. I
should get this and they say you know what?
I'm Gonna Give You Mercy today in this moment and
you don't get what you do deserve.
This is what God came to do.
He gave Grace and he gave
mercy and how'd he do all that verse 5 by the
washing of regeneration and renewal of the
Holy Spirit see in your sin. You deserve wrath
and judgment forever, but
God said, no instead. I'm going to take
your nasty sin clothes. I'm gonna
throw him into the washing machine of heaven and I'm gonna wash them clean not
by bleach, but by my own blood
and he gonna take him out. He's gonna re-cloth you and you're
gonna be perfect and you're gonna be new Snow White
completely white knew.
That's what he did.
in Mercy
Because you deserve.
to be condemned
But he didn't.
Instead he graciously gives salvation.
And notice he did all of that.
He did all of that to take that old man. That's you
and me in our sin. He took that old man and make each of
us a new man in him.
This is the third part old man. God Man shows
up now new man.
So what sync Corinthians 5:17 says?
Therefore if anyone is in Christ. He
is a new creation.
the old has passed away behold the
new
has come
the old man
You don't have to follow it anymore.
It's gone. It's done. God man says
you're a new man.
That's what he's done including in one really key
aspect here.
It's in Titus 3:7. He says so that we might become heirs.
Not Air Jordans, but Heir heirs.
And what's an error?
An air is is someone who's been named
to be in line for an inheritance?
Somebody who's probably in the family already, but if
not, they've been kind of brought into the family and put in the line to
say you're going to get this when I die or when I leave you're
gonna get your inheritance.
Now this we could camp on this theme for weeks. There's
so much here, but just think for a
second.
So that we would become heirs. Think about what that means Church.
You were separated from God in your sin.
You could do nothing about it.
The gulf was way too far.
You were his enemy.
In your sin.
Yet.
In his goodness and loving kindness.
He chose you to be in his
family.
And he paid for you to be in his
family with his son's life.
Like you see that do you see like and we're
not talking about just some kind of like Mafia Family like you're in
the family now like we're not talking about that. We're talking about you're in
God's family forever and ever with him as
his beloved child.
You were an enemy.
And you couldn't earn your way. You couldn't build a bridge across he
made the way by his own son sacrifice
on the cross.
To bring you back to him. What
great news is that
What great love that he would take
an enemy willingly self-sacrifice for
somebody who doesn't deserve it who doesn't have the ability
to pay him back and he says I'm gonna bring you
in.
That's love.
This is what the god-man did.
Took the old man.
Made him a new man.
That's the good news of the Gospel.
now
something could easily happen at this point.
I want to warn you about what could happen here as
we go forward. We're not careful because we've
just rejoiced in the gospel. The good news as our
treasure.
We've seen the Eternal hope that we have in him.
But as we move into what Titus 3 says are
response should be to that good news.
It's easy to kind of leave that behind and suddenly think
that the rest is up to you.
That Jesus Paid the down payment, but now
you're on the installment plan.
You have to somehow keep it or earn it again or something
along those lines.
No.
It's so simple to get there.
But don't downshift into some mutated
form of earning your salvation with just
a little Jesus dust sprinkled on top of it.
Because that's where it's so simple. That's what I live for decades.
Salvation don't forget is still.
By grace alone. It's not by works.
It's by grace alone. And I
say it so strongly because of what verse 8 says our
response should be to this good news.
This great love of God. Our response should be
to devote ourselves to Good Works.
That's what verse 8 says our response should be
Now we saw in chapter one false teachers were unfit for good works
because they didn't believe.
We should be zealous for good works Titus
2:14 said we should be ready for we should be excited to
live a life. That looks like that.
And I think this passage gives us three reasons why this is so important.
First because it it marks your
new life.
This is what it means to be a Christian to
be new. It marks off. Your new life
is a life full of good works.
because remember Ephesians 2
You were dead in your sins, but he
is now made you alive and not only made you
alive. He's made you a part of the family. Now, you're an heir
of eternal life. And so now you're called to
a new life in light of that.
to live out the family values you might say
what is God's value God's value
is good works.
to live like he does as Ephesians
says
verses 22 and 20 through 24 says you
are to put off your old self.
Which belongs to your former manner of life is corrupt
through deceitful desires.
And to be renewed in the spirit of your minds and
to put on the new self.
Created after the likeness of God in true righteousness
and holiness.
What he's saying is you're supposed to live a new life.
Right. The old man is gone. The new man has come
in the Salvation crisis offered he's
made you completely new and not only that he's made you a
child of God. And so just like you talk about with people
man. He's a spitting image of his father. He's a she's
a spitting image of her mother, right? What are we saying?
They look just like
Them they look just like the parent. This is what it means to be created
after the likeness like the image of
God means as a child.
You're supposed to be a spitting image of your father.
spitting image
look like act like
speak like follow him live out
a life of his values.
Such that people see him through you.
We'll talk a lot more about that later, but it's to put off
the old and to put on the new.
to live a new life
Listen, we're not just talking about showing up every couple Sundays and
and putting Christian on your social media profile.
Yet living the rest of your life as if you're in charge.
Somehow American Christianity has kind
of defaulted down into that.
And that's good enough.
No.
This is this is to fully surrender to the one
who has made you new spiritually.
To give your whole life to him. That's Revival. You want
to Awakening This Is Where It Starts because that's the way God designs you
to be was to be fully surrendered to
him. There's no other way.
So same thing like last week remember who
you are Christian?
Remember who you are who he's made you to
be in this if you've repented and believed in Jesus you are
new.
And the Holy Spirit has been planted inside of you
to rework and re-imagine and make different
your soul so that it looks
like the father.
And listen, this is true.
Even if you walked in here feeling beat up.
Even if you walked in here like a failure all week
and you can identify seen after seeing after scene of things that you
blew it in and you don't who didn't didn't follow him
in this way you blew up at your kids you did this at work
or whatever like even if you walked in here feeling like a
failure.
Remember who you are Christian?
And remember whose you are.
That if you have now, it's always
good to check right examine your heart but if
you've repented and believed you are his
and you are new.
The old is gone. The new has come.
So just lift that out now.
Because the enemy is going to try to pick and pick and
pick at your assurance.
And some days some weeks gonna be worse than others. It's going to
happen.
But remember what God has done for you.
Remember the gospel because that's how you then live
out the new life. You've been given in Christ.
There's a second reason to be devoted to Good Works.
Not only is it Mark your new life it also magnifies your new king.
It magnifies a life of Good Works magnifies your new
king.
Because remember verse 8 has a condition on all of
this the initial step into this it says
so that those who have believed in God may
be careful to devote themselves to Good Works.
Don't get this out of order. Only Believers can
actually do this.
It's a lot of Morality In The World Only Believers can do
good works this word belief though. That's the
condition.
That we're belief is is the same word translated all of the
New Testament as faith and as trust and as belief,
we tend to separate those things out but really
it's all the same idea that it's a confident Assurance
in what is being said
and the who is saying it.
I'm I believe I trust you.
I understand what you're saying and I'm gonna put my life in it. That's all
belief Faith Trust.
Here's the thing many in our world today.
Have a generic belief that there is a God out
there.
Right students, you ask people at school there would be very few
people who would actually deny and say it now,
there's no God. It's out there. I'm not saying it's not
but most people have a generic belief that there's a
God out there. Even James 2:19 says that
the demons have a monotheistic stance.
Yeah, of course. There's a God.
But the reason they're not saved.
And the reason so many people in our world are not saved.
Is because they do not believe the gospel.
They don't believe Jesus life death and Resurrection was what
it takes to be saved.
And haven't haven't trusted him with their life in that.
Because what happens when you believe that is you
by definition acknowledge him as your king.
Right, it's not just a separated. Like I'm gonna believe facts. It's a I'm
in I'm in.
And so I have said Jesus You're My
Lord.
You are the one who is in charge and what happens
then is as that new life happens. He gets
magnified because the only way that you can
run to him. The only way you can run
from self to others. The only way you can run from sin to
Purity in essence is him.
Now you can try you can set some moral boundaries and things like
that, but the only way truly those things can happen.
Is through your king changing you?
So listen, you might have seen today.
I've already said this once but you might have seen today that that your
life looks more like verse 3.
Than it does by being devoted to Good Works.
Like you see the old man defines you not the
new man.
Well, here's Jesus response to you.
Repent and believe in the gospel.
It's what Jesus said to do.
Turn from your sin and yourself and turn to
Jesus himself.
Turn to the one who can save you the only
one who can save you.
Like that's what he clearly said. You
might see the old man defines you. Okay? What
do you do you turn to him? Don't just turn to God in
general. Don't just turn to religion.
In fact don't even base this whole
thing on whether you walked an aisle sometime in your
past or whether you prayed a prayer sometime in your past
or whether you may man. I cried a whole lot at camp that one year
and that's what it's based on because that can all turn into some emotionalism.
That's not what we're talking about. We're saying to Jesus
You're My Lord. You are the king.
I am all yours.
That's it.
Not how you felt not how you respond. It's about
are you in your heart oriented to Jesus as
your king? I believe you said what? You said Jesus. I
trust you with my life. That's it.
And the moment you do that.
whole life
orients differently God Saves you he
makes you new and here's the third piece. He gives
you a new purpose.
He completely changes everything gives you a new purpose. That's
the third reason for good works. We see here in Titus 3.
It matches your new purpose.
Remember Ephesians 2:10 said that in Christ. You are his
workmanship.
That that word means Masterpiece his unique design
that he or he he did something
uniquely with you that he didn't do with me.
He designed you and then
it says he created in Christ. Hey, I
would say he recreated you in Christ Jesus for good
works.
He prepared in advance for you to do to walk
in them.
And so you've got Ephesians 2:10. This is what you're created for.
But then Titus 3:8 ended with these things
are excellent and profitable for people. They're useful.
They're beneficial. These are things that help others. They're
good for you, but they're also good for others
because remember the point
God doesn't need your good works.
But your neighbor does.
God doesn't need anything from you.
That's acts 17. Paul said that to the people
in Athens. They're like you can't provide any food for God. He's
got everything he needs he created everything. He gives you food.
but what he has created you for
is for good works that bless others.
You can't earn standing before God, but he changes you and
he uses you to bless other people.
As you humbly surrender as you sacrifice that then
blesses other people.
Okay. So what are we talking about here?
Good works is kind of a generic thought process out there.
So what do we mean? What are the good works we're talking about?
Infinite, but I'm going to give you at least a few look at verses 1
and 2 again first.
Right. This is our general attitude that we should have. How should
we live in life? Look at this now different
this would be than the world.
Remind them.
To be submissive to rulers and authorities.
to be obedient
To be ready for every good work.
To speak evil of no one to avoid quarreling to
be gentle.
And to show perfect courtesy toward all people.
You can't tell me that a life like that wouldn't stand out in the
world. We're in right now, right?
I mean just the chaos and vitriol all
over the world and you walk around like
that.
It's good work.
But I know we're talking more like okay, what are good works specifically day by
day. Okay, so what we're talking about in that?
Primarily is just following the leadership of
the Holy Spirit.
Because here's what's going to happen.
a distracted believer
will miss what? The holy spirit is prompting to
do in the moment.
But a devoted believer who's looking ready for good
works. We'll see what God wants them
to be involved in right now.
Don't be distracted be devoted and hear me.
Let me give you a couple ideas.
Or a couple examples of what would happen is sometimes we miss these
things. We're just distracted and we miss it. If we're devoted to
looking for these things. We'll see things like
opportunities to call a Widow on her anniversary.
And just you completely miss it, but you see the put on
your calendar. That's what I'm going to do.
Because I'm devoted.
To a good work like that or or to share the gospel with somebody
on the plane you put your buds in just move on like no there's God's put
that person there for a reason or even to
things like hosting students at your house for big
weekend and you completely oblivious to that but you
see the good work of that.
if you're looking
to weep with a woman who's been abandoned.
And you're so caught up in your own world that you miss out
on the good work that God has for you just to be with her.
but even more deeply to things like
like not walking in this room focused on self and
what I'm gonna get out of this but realizing that me singing in the
worship Gathering is actually blessing others around me.
Not whether I like it or not, but whether people are being blessed by me.
That's that's a focused Devotion to
good work.
Or even even things like persevering under a trial.
That you just you don't just go with the
Wind of the world. And what's what you're feeling right now, but you
say no Jesus. I'm sticking with you. I'm building my right my house on
the rock. I'm gonna stay steadfast and people see that.
even loving the jerk at work that everybody else
hates and gossips about
Is that not a good work?
Forgiven somebody who stole money from you.
leading times of prayer for repentance and Brokenness at
school
Church home
Good works.
Or think of the good and beneficial work of fostering and adopting.
A Ministry that's growing within our church. I'm so thankful for
that because James 1:27 says religion pure and
undefiled before God. The father is this to visit orphans
and widows in their Affliction and to keep
oneself unstained from the world.
Remember, this is why I'm
talking about this one specifically. Remember how this passage said
we are now heirs.
That we've been brought from enemy into the
family of God, and that's we've been we've been adopted into
God's family.
And so a good work would be to respond to that by just
imitating it here in the world.
And taking an orphan in and saying I am going to love
you and you are my child. What if
dozens of family stepped up here and just said, all right. We're in.
Hey, we're gonna devote ourselves to that good work. We're
in on that. There is already a support system here at the church, which is so
great. And so you can just step up and say all right, let's do it. How do we
get there?
It's a good work.
Devoted to it.
Or think of the good and beneficial work of
how you use God's money that he's entrusted to you.
He didn't just give that to you. It's by the way. It's his not yours. He didn't
just entrust that to you for your own comfort. And
for your benefit, that's his work through
you is to bless other people now. I know there's a lot of things
to give to
All over the world right now. It's fine to give to the things
that you're passionate about.
But one of the most important places to give is through your church
to help support those who teach the
word who disciple your kids who who do counseling and
do help with recovery and things like that. All of
those things are what we're to band together
to see what God can do because here's the
here's the reality.
I know many of you are like I can't give very much. I don't so why
is it's not gonna matter.
Listen, the beautiful part of this as the church is that we pull all
of these resources together to do things that are way
bigger than you can do by yourself.
Let me just think about that like so a middle school student like
I got ten bucks. Like well, you're ten bucks goes with everybody else's
to do all kinds of things. Just think of the huge
number of ways that you're generosity affects people.
I mentioned a couple you got recovery Ministry lives being transformed. You've
got counseling people getting help in that we've got
people every day walking in the office needing help with bills.
This helps people just very practically.
it takes the gospel to the Nations, we fund missionaries and support
things along those lines church planting replanting like
all of that discipling kids and students
like even this weekend, right this this happens all the faith
happens because you give
You see marriage Ministry?
Parenting like next week in widows singles college students
homebound.
Resources for knowing God's word you see all kinds of
things on and on and again, it's more than just money.
I get that but part of this part of
the point of this.
Is that better than anything else in your life?
Your pocketbook your bank account reflects your
priorities.
And the things we're talking about here are not for our own Comfort. We're
not doing this so that we can have better bigger nicer stuff.
We're doing this for the kingdom of God for Ministry purposes. And
there's so much more we can do.
Let me think of planting the gospel in places that have never heard it
before or places that are hard to get to or to love
people in our city that very few people are even loving right now. We can
have a chance to get into their lives and care for them like Jesus did
for us. So Step Up
This is worship. This is not giving to pay bills.
This is responsive worship to
the Lord as you give financially.
Don't forget this that your new
purpose.
my new purpose
is to respond to the great grace of God in
Jesus Christ by devoting ourselves to
Good Works.
That our lives look different that
each of us live out a unique design God
who has just who's sovereignly creative
and he's put it all together and he makes the body fit together
in such a way that all of us complement each other and we
see God do crazy cool things through all of us
playing our part. That's all by his
grace and mercy
For the purpose of blessing others around us.
See, here's the here's the reality.
God could bless and serve and provide for
people in all kinds of other ways.
God could get the gospel.
To people in all kinds of different ways.
But he's chosen to use you and me.
pretty inefficient
We blow it all the time. We mess it up. We don't
do it all the time.
I would pick a different way.
But he's chosen to use you and me Christian.
He's chosen to use the church.
And what he does in that is that more than anything
else shows him off.
Because he uses us.
And it works.
He does it he does it through US
somehow and it shows him off.
That's what Matthew 5:16. Jesus said let
your light shine before others so that they
may see your good works and give glory to your father
who is in heaven.
The fact that we're doing these things points to
him, that's the goal to glorify him in everything
in our lives. And since we can't do it without him.
That's why we need to surrender to him for it.
We can't think because we have a lot of money a lot of people
that we can do this we can make it happen. No, we desperately
need him.
Part for me. You can do nothing John 15 says and so
we must surrender we must open our hands we must be
broken before him to respond to his
great grace with a transformed life.
to say
with the hymn writer of old.
Nothing in my hand. I bring
simply to thy cross I cling.
That's where our power comes from church.
So let's cling to him for it.